The third type of cryptographic
algorithms is hash functions.
Hash functions don't use keys.
A hash function computes the hash, or
the message digest of data of any size.
The hash or the message digest is
a fixed length output, typically,
in the range of 128 to 512 bits.
Hash functions are ,typically,
useful authentication and
protection of message authenticity and
integrity.
In order to provide these services,
hash functions must satisfy
these following properties.
First, it should be relatively easy to
compute a hash of a given message m.
This would make hardware and
software implementations practical.
In other words, we want to be able
to compute hash very efficiently.
Second, for given hash value,
it should be completely infeasible to
find the original message m, such that,
the hash of m is this given hash value.
This so called one way
property is very important.
For example, suppose Alice wants
to authenticate herself to Bob.
Alice would hash a secret,
that she shares with Bob,
as with the current timestamp together.
For example,
she can concatenate the secret s,
with the current timestamp together,
and then,
hash over the concatenated value,
and send the hash value over to Bob.
Bob would know that, this must be Alice,
because he can check the current time
stamp, and he has the share secret S.
In other words,
Bob can take the current time stamp
concatenate with the shared secret s,
and compute his own hash, and compare
with the hash value with the received
hash value, if they match, then he knows
that he's been communicating with Alice.
Now, because the hash value is
transmitted over the Internet, and
we must assume that an attacker
can obtain any value that's
transmitted over the Internet.
That is, the attacker may be
able to obtain this hash value.
If the hash function is not one way,
that means the attacker can
reverse the hash function, and
find out the input to the hash function,
which includes the share secret s.
If the attacker knows
the share secret s,
then the attacker can impersonate
Alice to Bob, or Bob to Alice.
So this is, an example,
that demonstrates that the one way
property of hash function is essential.
Another property of hash function
is that given a message m1,
it should be computationally infeasible
to find a different message m2,
such that they have
the exact same hash value.
This is the weak collision
resistant property.
This is an essential property for
message authenticity and
integrity protection.
Imagine the following situation.
Alice wants to send a message,
m, to Bob.
And she wants to make
sure that Bob knows that
Alice is the real author of m.
So Alice is going to send m,
along with a sign hash of m,
meaning that Alice would hash m and
then, sign hash, using her private key.
Now an attacker can look at
the traffic on the Internet, and
find that Alice is sending m,
and assign hash to Bob.
If the weak collision resistant
property is not there,
then the attacker may be able to
find a different message m pi,
such that the hash of m pi would
be the same as the hash of m,
therefore, although the attacker has
changed the message from m to m pi,
the signature will still match.
And therefore, when Bob receives m pi,
and the original signature of hash of m,
Bob will not know that the message
has been changed from m to m pi.
This is a simple example to show that
the weak collision of system property
is essential to protect message
authenticity and integrity.
There's a stronger version of
the collision resistant property.
It says that it should be
computationally infeasible to find
different messages, m1 and m2, such that
they have exactly the same hash value.
This is a stronger property
because it prevents the attacker
from coming up with two different
messages, that have the same hash value.
Again, this property is essential for
protecting message authenticity and
integrity.
For example, suppose Bob can write a IOU
message, and send it to Alice to sign.
Again, the way that Alice will sign it
is to hash the message first, and then,
sign the hash, using a private key.
If Bob can find two different messages,
that have the same hash value,
one of which requires Alice
to pay a small amount, and
the other requires her to
pay a very large amount.
And the two different messages
have exactly the same hash.
Suppose Bob sends the message with
a small amount for Alice to sign.
After Bob receives Alice's signature
on the message with the small amount,
Bob can then go around and claim
that Alice owes her a larger amount,
because the two different messages,
have the same hash.
And the signatures
would then be the same.
It should be obvious
that if a hash function
satisfies the strong
collision resistant property,
it automatically satisfies the weak
collision system property.